plenty of games feature classes or roles
which are essential
if you want to win
don't be on the backlight income
splendid but the stopwatches come on
through flight drive with a huge narrow
ultimate maybe this is it but fbx still
firing out
goes five
daddy
what how does viper do it rockstar
positions such as duelists ady carries
dps players and opers often steal the
thunder because of their flashy frags
and natural inclination towards
embracing the spotlight kenny first at
the bat he finds a shot but he's being
pressured up close he needs shocks to
support him he's watching for a flight
but what
oh my god kenny gets an incredible kill
against sixer and sure there are certain
characters that have pop-off potential
despite being designed for more selfless
players but the primary goal of any
support player worth their salt is to
keep their teammates alive
which
let's be honest isn't exactly the
sexiest job and is certainly one of the
most thankless i said all support
players suck
the ones that just suck a little less
climb it's true
it's true they're terrible they're all
horrible while other players get to clap
cheeks on the front line supports often
find themselves sitting on the fringes
of the action not getting the credit
that they deserve
but invalorant specifically one agent
has won the hearts of every duelist
player in the entire community for
running around and saving their bacon
since the early days of the game's
development i am of course talking about
sage but
needs to find a couple more though
what is the trickiest part
way shade
shadows are you serious right now
mommy sage has been tending to her
children for the past two years but not
too long after the game's release one
player made it his mission to eliminate
all stereotypes associated with the
agent meet william grimm shriner
valorent's first true battle sage a
content creator who has built an entire
brand around borderline game breaking
boosts
no chocolate
it's a deep smoke for you
so how exactly did grimm become the most
infamous sagemaine in valorant have his
sage walls become a genuine problem
within the community
and how did surfing in cs go inspire one
of riot's worst game balancing
nightmares
i saw him
he's flying king slanging hello
man
uh idiom phoenix
okay so before we commence with the sage
simping i must remind y'all to like the
video sub to the channel and turn on
those pesky notifications
y'all probably don't know this but there
was a time when your boy dimitri did
actually play a [ __ ] ton of valorant and
fancied himself a died in the wall of
battle saver oh no who knows maybe if
this video hits a million views
i'll run it back
so much better than me
all right so before grim started making
a name for himself dumpstering scrubs
with his insane sage walls
where did this 19 year old madman story
actually begin well grimm grew up in
lawrenceville georgia a small city just
south of atlanta where from a young age
he fell in love with tennis when i was
really young like seven that's when i
started tennis ggc it's georgia gwinnett
college that's where i started it's up
in lawrence so
they have like a camp there for like i
wouldn't say prodigies but like pretty
decent players that's where i would go
and uh practice when i was young outside
of school and sports grim found himself
with a lot of free time so
like any self-respecting little tyke he
dived into gaming
but he didn't start off playing the
games you might expect first game i ever
played
um was uh super smash was melee back on
the gamecube
my cousins had it and i thought i was
sick and i played that for days and days
on end i never stopped playing so i
could beat them from then on he split
his time between tennis and melee but
once one of his friends introduced him
to pc gaming he discovered a new passion
counter-strike now grimm initially
played source back in 2011 but when
global offensive released in 2012 he
really sunk his teeth into it
although he wasn't exactly playing the
game as it had been intended you see
like many others in the counter-strike
community grimm became hooked on surfing
but more specifically
combat surfing it's basically like um
like surfing but
with shooting involved mid-air so like
you surf and you shoot mid-air and you
keep surfing and you have to be really
fast or else you'll die anyway as grim
entered high school he began to undergo
some
changes
god it felt weird to say that
after shooting up to a towering six foot
four in his junior year he pivoted
towards playing basketball despite
spending hours on the court and playing
percussion in his high school band grimm
still made time to play actual cs go and
he began thinking it could be his future
played face at esea all that junk uh
ended up getting uh level nine and then
a plus on esea
and i was like trying to get bro i
wasn't that like that insane but i was
trying i wanted to see if i could do
that but i couldn't because uh it's
really hard to get into cs unfortunately
for grim by 2020
he pretty much given up all hope of
being able to go pro in counter-strike
like a lot of any players at the time
but in the spring of that year he found
the game that would take him closer to
becoming a professional gamer
valerant
first i was uh i was watching uh xqc
play the beta and i was like yeah i'm
just gonna so i got the key like the
second day i think that's when i first
got got into it i thought it was like oh
this is sick like it's like a cs cs in
overwatch like i was like oh this is
like these are the games with during the
beta most players were just learning the
basics about each agent but grimm took a
liking to one agent in particular and it
might surprise you but it wasn't sage
you see thanks to his mastery of
movement via combat surfing in
counter-strike grimm was first drawn to
raise
using her satchels to move around the
map and catch unsuspecting opponents off
guard was very appealing to him and he
quickly realized that her skill ceiling
was almost endless of course being a
ray's main grimm was naturally drawn to
fleitz's content but after finding
himself in a lobby with the british
blast pack king himself grimm decided
that maybe reyes wasn't for him he put
out a tweet or something saying like i
don't know how to tweet it no yeah i
think he was just in in the stream he
was like i'm gonna do some games this
was like oh my god this is my chance i'm
gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna raise
different put him in a montage and so i
was like oh let me get into like i was
like stay with the chat i was like give
me in yeah we're good we got in the same
team yeah i remember that we got on the
same team and i was like i can't i get
raised to him now i was like oh this is
jesus and so i went sage because like
back then it was like sage and raised
like he this age boosted the raise
and that's how i was so
yeah i was boosting him i ended up out
fragging him that game and i played
really well i think i damned him shortly
after i was like hey yo we should like
we should like we should queue up i'll
be your stage every stage [ __ ] john
said it sounds like i'll boost y'all
boost you around i'll i'll do that and i
was cause i was like i was like oh this
is sick like i play with flights
after playing with flights
grimm realized that he was gonna have to
do something pretty special to stand out
in the growing sea of valor and content
creators
so
he decided to become the game's resident
sagemaine and that's when he began
working on his walls and so i started
experimenting i went on a scent and a
custom one day and i was jumping off of
generator on a site and
i remember one time i shift walked off
and i jumped
and the wall was longer and i was like
oh my god like this is huge like i'm on
top and the wall's long and i was like
wait what else can i do and so i think
after that i spent a whole month just in
customs looking at all the walls i could
do every single spot one wiz
um everything everything under the sun
now as expected grimm doesn't exactly
place age in the typical supportive
style that many of you know while most
sage players are out here just trying to
survive grim is on the front lines
taking aggressive peaks holding absurd
angles and catching his opponents off
guard
[Applause]
he's unaware he doesn't know how it
works
yeah you can't clear this side
oh my god
you fought well
another one
after flights saw some of grimm's nutty
sage plays he convinced him to take a
stab at creating some content
there was only one problem
grimm had no [ __ ] idea how youtube
worked luckily for him flights helped
with the seo side of things and he
received some free exposure when a
spanish valorent content creator named
black valorant helped showcase some of
grimm's sagetech not long after having
the spotlight shown on him by black
valorant grimm returned home one day to
discover that his youtube channel had
gone from under 100 subs to over 7 000.
to capitalize on the momentum he was
building grim began pumping out video
after video showcasing more of his
bizarre sage walls and as his viewership
continued to climb he wanted to push his
content to the next level by joining an
orc i think at that point i was like a
300k person at that point and this is
when flights was signed to t1 already he
really he really wanted me on there
because like it'd be cool because that's
how we started together and then we'd be
finishing together i was like oh that's
pretty cool not long after flights was
signed grimm was flown out to la to film
content for t1 and in june of 2021 he
was announced as a content creator for
the orc
since then grimm's sub count on youtube
has nearly doubled and he has become the
go-to sage content creator on twitch
but it's not just valorem players whose
attention he's grabbed
he believes that riot has been keeping a
close eye on him too i swear to god they
watch my videos i swear all my life
they've done a couple where i'm like
okay like they've seen that in my video
and they got they patched it although
riot has tried to nerf him by removing
some of his favorite boosts grimm has
not been deterred he continues to find
new and unique ways to dumpster his
opponents on the server that's the best
comment i've ever got
yeah i'm not that bad
i'll take that
bro
okay
[Music]
while grimm has embraced his role as his
game's most popular sagemaine by
providing his viewers with educational
content
that's not actually his endgame he wants
to use his success on youtube and twitch
to grow beyond valorant because despite
his obvious love for the game he sees
countless other opportunities when it
comes to content creation i mean
eventually i want to be a variety
schumer i think i want to go like on the
ride of like branching out uh when when
like
i feel like it's possible
uh like every other variety shimmer like
they get big on one game and then they
branch out when you know the audience is
big enough i want to do that i want to
be less of a sageball guy more of like a
a grim
the truth
is that it's really important that
valorent has radicals like grim who are
constantly pushing the boundaries and
forcing people to rethink what's
actually possible in the game he's
helping to free agents like sage from
the shackles of convention an inspiring
players to think twice before locking in
their picks esports thrive on
experimentation and it's crucial that we
have creators and competitors who are
willing to do crazy [ __ ] in the name of
progress
and the work he's doing isn't just being
absorbed by ranked demons out there as
more and more of his crafty walls are
finding their way into the repertoires
of pro players no matter how much riot
keeps tabs on him grimm is gonna keep
pushing the envelope and coming up with
new headaches for them
and his opponents on the server and no
matter where his content creation career
takes him there is no question that he's
already left his mark on the valorent
community his name is now synonymous
with the very agent he mains
so every time you get cheesed by a sage
wall
it'll be
hard not to think of grim whoa what am i
looking at
oh what
he got an obliterated new cap
spike down hey once again
oh my god
bro i missed battle sage
i missed battle sage there was a time
when sage was the best entry fragger in
in valor bro
i miss those days she used to be so much
crazier than she is now like her heels
used to be insane the wall used to have
a longer distance on the cast time like
when i played her seriously she was
insane she was utterly ridiculous